Therese may which hold us in check as
this weekend
trying to build support for her brexit
deal nothing to see here
and this morning on its a fridge on
Sunday we're joined by a man who we hope
can steer us through the contradictory
reports and tell us what's really
happening joining us now is the
Chancellor of Exchequer Philip Hammond
thank you very much for being with us
this morning
pleasure so translate what is going on
well look in just over two weeks time we
run the risk of facing a very stark
choice between leaving the EU with no
deal or not leaving the EU at all it is
essential that we get a deal done and
I've always believed that the deal the
Prime Minister has negotiated is a
perfectly sensible way for us to proceed
to leave the EU it's not perfect she's
acknowledged that but it's a perfectly
sensible way forward but if we can't get
well if we can't build a majority behind
that deal then the House of Commons has
to decide how it does want to go forward
what it can agree to and it's clear that
there's going to be an opportunity over
the next few days for the House of
Commons if it doesn't approve the Prime
Minister's deal to find to try to find a
majority behind another proposition that
it can take forward now I'm very keen to
talk about brexit and for a large
proportion of the interview of course
but I just want to address some of these
reports in the Sunday newspapers which
are effectively saying that we're in the
middle of a coup I mean has the Prime
Minister run out of Road no I don't
think that's the case at all this is not
about the Prime Minister or any other
individual this is about the future of
our country and changing Prime Minister
wouldn't help us changing party in
government wouldn't help us we've got
we've got to address the question of
what type of brexit is acceptable to
Parliament what type of way forward
Parliament can agree on so that we can
avoid what would be an economic
catastrophe of a No Deal exit and also
what would be a very big challenge to
confidence in our political system if we
didn't exit at all so we have to avoid
both of those alternatives and find a
way through the middle with
deal that works for Britain and
guarantees our future prosperity because
according to reports today your way
through the middle is to try and see if
David Livington the de facto Deputy
Prime Minister could actually become
some kind of caretaker leader and steer
Parliament through a deal it is that
false no that's not right at all my
position is this isn't about individuals
this is about how we move forward the
Prime Minister's deal is my preferred
way forward but I'm realistic that we
may not be able to get a majority for
the Prime Minister's deal and if that is
the case then Parliament will have to
decide not just what it's against but
what it is for Parliament will have to
come together around a proposition that
can that can gather a majority and what
I'm hearing in Parliament at the moment
is lots of different ideas from
different factions but that won't solve
the problem
those backbench leaders of different
groups have got to get themselves
together in a room and decide what they
can compromise on because if Parliament
won't compromise we'll end up at the end
of this process no further forward than
we were at the beginning of it I mean
some people say that it's the Prime
Minister though who is the roadblock to
getting that kind of deal that you
clearly so want I can just show you the
quote that one cabinet minister gave to
The Sunday Times today cabinet minister
telling the Sunday Times the end is nigh
she won't be Prime Minister in 10 days
time I mean there's a reason we have to
ask these questions because anything
will be very concerned about where we
are at the world watching will see that
we have just over two weeks to complete
this process before we get to the 12th
of April that the new deadline that the
council has set last week to be talking
about changing the players on the board
frankly is self-indulgent at this time
we have to decide how we want to proceed
is it a No Deal brexit which I think
would be a catastrophe is it
no brexit at all which I think would
massively undermine confidence in our
political system or is it the Prime
Minister's deal and if not the Prime
Minister's deal some variant on it that
Parliament can agree
to Parliament has to come together and
make a decision over the coming days and
the government has been clear that it
will allow Parliament the time and the
space to do that if it can't agree the
Prime Minister's deal to say what it can
agree and I know you're clearly keen to
draw them back to door things back to
the vote so we're gonna be sitting on
breaks in the House of Commons let's
wait of course but at the same time I
just want to focus for a moment we have
a prime minister where members of her in
cabinet are saying the end is nigh the
chair of the 1922 Committee of
backbenchers Gwen Brady has gone into
down in the street to say MPs want you
to go members of her own whips office
are telling her to her face that she
needs to go how can she actually carry
on in these circumstances well I don't
think that would solve the problem
everybody's very frustrated the Prime
Minister herself has acknowledged that
she was expressing her frustrations on
Wednesday evening when she spoke to the
nation changing
well she's expressed that she was she
was setting out her frustrations and
she's acknowledged that many people it
across Parliament are also very
frustrated by this process but changing
the players doesn't solve the problem
that changing the party in government
wouldn't solve the problem the the
problem is that we as a nation have to
decide how to deliver brexit people
approach you toach to make an
intervention to the Prime Minister I I
speak to all sorts of colleagues and I'm
not going to divulge the content of
those conversations but I will be
absolutely upfront people are very
frustrated and people are desperate to
find a way forward in the just over two
weeks that we've got to resolve this
issue do you think part of the
frustration comes from the fact that
people struggle to really know what the
Prime Minister is thinking I mean do you
know what she's thinking well I I know
that the Prime Minister believes that
getting the deal done
is the only way to go forward with our
country intact and to be able to rebuild
and ensure that Britain does have a
brighter future if we crash out with no
deal we will face all sorts of economic
problems and if we don't leave the EU at
all
we will face huge problems of confidence
in our in our democracy so we have a
solution which is a deal and the Prime
Minister's deal is on the table but if
people cannot accept the Prime
Minister's deal then they have to come
together around a variant of it and it
has to be a variant that's deliverable
not some unicorn and the government's
been clear that we will make time we'll
make sure that Parliament has time over
the next few days to be able to do that
is the brexit deal the trees most brexit
tell is it dead well I personally think
that it's the best way forward I think
it's a perfectly sensible and coherent
deal we've spent a long you can think
it's a good deal but it's still in
knowledge that it's dead but I
acknowledge that it's looking very
difficult to bring together a majority
for it but that isn't enough for
Parliament to say we won't vote for the
Prime Minister's deal Parliament isn't
that what is now going to be confronted
with the time and the space to make its
own decision about how we should change
that deal how we should adjust that deal
in order to be able to go forward it has
to be something that the EU can agree to
so it has to accept the withdrawal
agreement that we've negotiated at its
centre but if Parliament has a clear
majority view about what we need to do
to the deal package to make it
acceptable to Parliament then let's hear
about it this week and then we can move
forward ok well let's be clear are you
saying then that there will be in what's
called indicative votes where MPs
effectively had given a range of bricks
at options to vote on to work out what
there might be majority for is that
happening this week well the government
said the week before last that if we
didn't get the deal done we would make
space available for Parliament
in the two weeks following the council
so this week next week
for Parliament to try to come to a
consensus view around a single
proposition we've also got on the order
paper for tomorrow an amendment in the
name of Oliver latwon which would create
parliamentary space to do the same thing
so one way or another Parliament is
going to have the opportunity this week
to decide what
is in favor of and I hope that it will
take that opportunity if it can't get
behind the Prime Minister's deal to say
clearly and unambiguously what it can
get yeah so because you actually back
the Oliver let win amendment that the
government no government set out its own
process but the Oliver let win amendment
is on the order paper and you know
candidly there's a significant chance
that it may carry so will these votes be
free base that's something we haven't
decided yet that'll depend on the
process you can't really ask Palmer to
have it say in an open way and not have
free votes can you well we will decide
when we see what the propositions are
what what is being put forward how the
government will respond to those but the
purpose of this exercise is to see if we
can get to a view a proposition which is
acceptable across Parliament and if if
our deal is not acceptable to Parliament
then of course we have to engage with
Parliament to look for a version of it
that will be acceptable okay
well I know it's early days exactly
what's gonna be on the on the paper but
this is what Sky News has been told some
of these options could be now in the
spirit of compromise and know you think
that Theresa Mays deal is the best way
forward are there any other scenarios
that you could potentially back I mean
the Prime Minister's deal plus a customs
union for example is there any other
compromises that you would be happy with
look my number one priority is to ensure
that we leave the EU and that we leave
with a deal so I would remove the top
one and the bottom one from the list
because both of those would have very
serious and negative consequences for
our country and beyond that I want to
see a compromise and the essence of
compromise is that nobody gets
everything they want and what I what I
want to hear from senior figures across
Parliament is that they recognise that
if this process is going to be
successful there will have to be
compromises all around what I'm hearing
is the matter where anyone what I'm
hearing at the moment is protagonists
for individual options here staking out
their corner and arguing their case but
what we need to hear
people saying you know I prefer X but I
am perfectly content to live with y come
on then you can you can you can either
way we have to have a wafer we know that
you prepared the Prime Minister's deal
but I argue for the Prime Minister's
deal but but the most important thing
for me is that we have a way forward
which means we leave the European Union
with a negotiated settlement with the
withdrawal agreement and then we can
move on as a nation and I do believe
that we have a bright future in front of
us but only if we do this in a smooth
and orderly way I noticed you didn't
take the second referendum off the table
I mean is it something that you could
accept for example if the Prime
Minister's deal goes through Parliament
on the guarantee that it will then be
put to a public vote so I'm not sure
that there's a majority in parliament in
support of second referendum but it's a
perfectly coherent proposition many
people will be strongly opposed to it
but it's a coherent proposition and it
deserves to be considered along with the
other proposals that you've got on the
list now of course not everyone is happy
with the idea of these so-called
indicative votes we can have a look now
at something that Steve Baker has said
he's a former minister of brexit
supporter he has said that they would be
national humiliation is imminent through
these indicative votes the wrong
conservatives have the levers of power
are you one of the wrong buttons by
which I take it Steve Baker means
conservatives who don't agree with his
very hard line view of what breaks it
should look like are you one of the
wrong conservatives with the leaves
apart you thinking I'm sure if you are
Steve Baker I would definitely be one of
those wrong conservatives and he won't
be very happy woody to be reading the
papers that you're trying to according
to you in the Sunday Times the mell on
Sunday trying to get David Lydon turn
into the top job something well that's
that's not the case what I'm trying to
do is find a way forward I'd prefer it
to be the Prime Minister's deal but if
it can't be the Prime Minister's deal
then it has to be a deal and Parliament
has to come together quickly around the
deal that it can support I mean this is
all going to take time isn't it are we
realistically looking at a long
extension and fighting the European
elections no I don't think it has to at
all if
Parliament passes the Prime Minister's
deal this week next week or comes
together around an alternative
proposition that is deliverable that the
European Union could agree to then
there's no reason why we cannot leave on
May the 22nd in inline with the decision
of the council last week the other
alternative of course is leaving with no
deal you know the Prime Minister better
than most do you think that's something
that she could stomach I'm sure that the
Prime Minister will act always in what
she sees as the best national interest
and I am very clear that it would not be
in our national interest to leave with
no deal it would cause catastrophic
economic dislocation in the short term
and in the longer term it will leave us
with a smaller economy poorer as a
nation relative to our neighbours in the
European Union that is not the future
for Britain that I came into politics to
deliver I want to see Britain leading
from the front I want to see Britain as
a more prosperous nation not a less
prosperous nation so would you resign in
order to stop no doubt well I'm not I
said this isn't about individuals this
is about getting the process right and
making sure we have the right outcome
right but I'm at the press but I have
always been clear that I believe No Deal
would be a catastrophic ly bad outcome
for our country and I will always do
everything I can to argue for exiting
with a negotiated deal and a smooth path
to a new future relationship with the EU
the last time we spoke just before the
budget you said that if there was no
deal then there would need to be a new
approach to the economy and a new budget
so do you have like an emergency budget
in your top drawer just in case no
because we don't know exactly what the
circumstances would be but I've said
many times and I said again in the
spring statement week before last
both the Bank of England running
monetary policy and the Treasury running
fiscal policy have a clear set of tools
available and if we did find ourselves
leaving with No Deal we've done a huge
amount of preparation work across the
economy we've spent four and a half
billion pounds on contingency
for a No Deal exit and we will have
tools available to us to help support
the economy in the short term including
the 26 billion pounds fiscal buffer that
I described at the spring statement but
that will only help us to smooth our
path it will not avoid the long term
costs of a No Deal exit it will not
avoid our economy being smaller and the
British people being poorer over the
longer term and then just finally
Chancellor we're in a situation where
this was supposed to be the week when we
live in the EU instead the newspapers
are absolutely full of talk of
leadership chaos we're facing
potentially the biggest crisis
politically and economically for a
generation if the Conservative Party get
it wrong do you think you'll never be
forgiven well clearly the stakes are
very high both for our nation and for us
as a party of government that's why it
is so important that we come together to
deliver an orderly brexit that is what
the Conservative Party is about managing
the country managing government we have
to demonstrate that we can do this I
know it's been a difficult process but
even now we have it in our grasp to
agree the prime ministers deal or if we
can't do that to agree another deal in
Parliament to implement it for the 22nd
of May to leave the EU with an
implementation period to the end of 2020
as agreed in the in the negotiated deal
so that we have a smooth path and we are
able to negotiate a future close trading
relationship with the European Union
after we've ceased to be a member okay
Chancellor Philip Hammond thank you very
much